garda world
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bon je vais je vous le cacher mais
franchement me retrouver ici à la télé
c'est je trouve ça aussi surréaliste que
bachar el-assad qui reçoit le prix nobel
donc je suis pas là pour critiquer la
télé r je trouve ça vachement utilise
comme un des seuls endroits où se
rencontrent l'élite et les chômeurs
merci de faire l'élite en tout cas ce
soir quand même 41 mille 300 chômeurs de
plus en un mois
chômeur métiers d'avenir
en même temps ces chiffres seraient
beaucoup plus faible si les nouveaux
chômeurs avait la pudeur ne pas le faire
savoir
c'est quand même dingue hein ce mal
français se vanter de son inactivité
l'arrogance des chômeurs
j'étais venu pourquoi déjà oui donc je
disais thierry d'autres trucs s'appelle
salut les terriens pas moi je n'ai pas
trouvé de très vert ce que tu le
retrouves à enfin est-ce qu'ils ont si
génial à défendre je suis pas
allé martial je trouve ça beaucoup plus
intelligent tu vois il cherche pas à
nous connaître
le preuve d'un génie quoi d'ailleurs ça
pouvait continuer ça serait bien nous
pour se faire remarquer qu'est ce qu'on
fait on lance des sons dans l'espace
avec de la musique de mozart face mais
aucun intérêt quoi franchement on
devrait plutôt envoyé ce à quoi je sais
pas
non c'est bon
c'est ce que c'est
et veut dans ta chatte ouais enfin je
traduis excusez moi de défendre le
français qui ont soit disant les
rebelles de l'été quelle arnaque si
c'était si rebel que ça il aurait fait
la macarena dans une mosquée
elles ont pris deux ans de goulag deux
ans de gaulle la preuve que poutine
s'est assouplie quoi
moi je trouve ça leur fera quand même du
bien quoi le goulag on trouve
l'inspiration aux boules 1 6 o jenny
s'il n'était pas allé au goulag il
aurait écrit quoi
l'archipel de ma cuisine le trou dont
camille martien surtout restez chez vous
ne venez pas parce que ici ça n'a aucun
intérêt que je veux dire politiquement
c'est dur c'est dur la gauche est au
pouvoir quoi les bolchéviques sont
passées
depuis que la gauche est passé quoi moi
je me promène jamais tout seul toujours
avec une femme c'est la parité
puis que la gauche est passée cette
femme ne peut pas être de ma couleur
quoi ça s'appelle la diversité
bah c'est pas le seul effet de l'arrivée
de la gauche ça fait fuir les riches
exemple stéphane guillon
[Applaudissements]
après je suis pas là pour dézinguer la
gauche le président enfin c'est un mec
c'est rené coty junior
il a son style à son style roulant break
manque plus que l'autocollant j'aime la
plagne quoi
il a pris un break parce qu un
corbillard c'était un peu trop tôt
encore ce truc qui va arriver quoi on
lui reproche de ne pas avoir le même
rythme que sarko quel génie cas sarko
quand même
non mais c'est quand même incroyable ce
type qui arrive à convaincre les
français que l'hystérie c'est un truc
rassurant
toute façon je comprends pour les
français c'est pas facile quoi passer
d'un coût de 24 heures chrono à louis la
brocante
car heureusement qu'il est en couple
avec une fille un peu tendu parce que
enfin le couple hollande révélèrent ça
me fait penser à une éponge de cuisine
peuvent voir un côté qui grattent
l'autre qui absorbe
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il paraît que vous vous y être pour
quelque chose vous avez de ré ouvrir un
site de rencontres
non mais en tous cas avait on
s'attendait à tout avec hollande sauf
aux feux de l'amour quoi c'est le truc
vraiment qu'est ce qu'est ce qu'elle lui
trouve à hollande c'est quoi sont déjà
il ya des rumeurs il paraît qu'elle un
côté reptilien dragueur comme ça mais
j'ai une copine elle a pris l'ascenseur
avec lui c'est ce qu'il a fait
rien
dsk il a vu ça ici dit peter ce mec
c'est un fou
alors vous me direz l'opposition existe
web
l'ump coiffe team fillon contre team
copé la france coule il joue à
intervilles quoi c'est le truc mais
qu'est ce qu'ils ont tous à l'ump de se
réclamer de sarkozy je comprends pas il
est mort
facile et tellement génial faut le
rappeler quoi je sais pas énorme vas-y
rachid fin
mais tout ça c'est de l'anecdote ça
c'est du microcode c'est de la petite
tambouille ça sera nous il ya des choses
beaucoup plus graves en france beaucoup
plus grave audrey pulvar gère les
inrocks
s'imagine c'est comme christine boutin
chez playboy
playmate du mois bernadette soubirous en
string un rêve de gosse
puis à l'insécurité bon ça c'est réglé
manuel valls sarko qui s'habille chez
zara tu vois le truc
il n'y a pas de miracle il ya moins de
fric à gauche les gens ils font un peu
moins des fins ils peuvent pas quoi
faire rachida vous êtes une fois d'el
hamma rachid quoi y'a un truc
il ya toutes ces polémiques sur les roms
tout ça ça va ça ça pour des gens du
voyage que tu chichi hallyday dans des
placements
[Applaudissements]
mais bon ya pas que ça
économiquement c'est dur quoi c'est la
crise la crise est tellement forte quand
même des braqueurs s'attaque à emmaüs
cimade t'imagines la réunion
préparatoire dégâts demain on se fait
quoi secours populaire restos du coeur
ah non pas les restos j'ai assez de
boîtes de cassoulet quoi faut faire au
dessus
pour l'argent c'est un problème bon ça
la france dépense mal son argent c'est
une évidence
bon on n'est pas les seuls à le qatar
investit bien dans le psg
le qatar qui investit au psg c'est comme
un gagnant de l'euromillions lui dit
alors vous allez faire quoi de votre
argent à moi je vais acheter de la dette
grecque
toute façon moi le sport ch pour à moi
j'ai dû me taper les jeux olympiques y
avait rien d'autre alors il ya des
jolies images je veux pas dénigrer ses
c'est le truc manaudou et son frère way
[ __ ] moi l'inceste toujours
bas ici on a qui aiment pas fait autre
chose quoi
évidemment après les jeux olympiques on
doit se taper les paralympiques quel
régal
cour des miracles fait de le ps quoi
concours lépine de la béquille
orthopédique enfin je sais pas qui
regarde ça
ça soit un problème de calendrier quoi
les jeux olympiques et après les
paralympiques chute c'est comme voir une
course de caisses à savon après une
course de formule 1
mais il ya des nouvelles rassurantes il
ya des johnny est vivant
je vais parce que lui c'est un rocker
c'est un iconoclaste un mec choper une
bronchite à saint barth quoi
voilà la malaria au pôle nord
comme un puceau qui décèdent la syphilis
quoi séparé
mais bon peut-être finir sur une
nouvelle un peu optimiste et positif
prix de l'essence baisse ouais ouf on va
enfin pouvoir s'acheter un timbre
pas belle la vie et pour être sûr de ne
rien rater de 1h10 tube abonnez vous je
m'étais 1 pouces bleus